is on the program this morning it's
great to see let's talk about texas
first of all though you've seen the
terrible news overnight and i was just
sharing with our viewers there have been
more mass shootings in the u.s so far
this year than there have been days in
the year
um your thoughts well these are
absolutely harrowing and we've we've
seen multiple incidents of this sort
over the the years
you know i've seen interviews with today
with some of the parents of
uh you know parents who've lost uh
children to such you know terrible
terrible events you know and obviously
it'll it'll reopen again a debate in the
u.s about their gun laws um which
obviously are very very different to
what we have here uh in the uk they have
a very different culture and a different
approach there but i i think for sure
it's going to reopen that debate for
them
and thank goodness for that i'm sure
lots of parents will be saying this
morning um let's talk about partygate
should we um eyewitness reports we heard
last night um
is it worse than you thought
well look i think we've known about a
lot of these uh events for some time
though that sue gray uh alluded to them
in a first interim report obviously the
police have investigated um all of these
events as well they gave the prime
minister a fixed penalty notice in
respect
of one of them um and obviously we'll
we'll see what the final sugree report
uh says it's expected you know sometime
this week some speculation that it might
be uh today um and we'll have to to see
what the final report is but look the
prime minister said all along he's given
an account of uh how he saw these
different events he's paid the fixed
penalty notice but he absolutely
recognizes that there were failings he's
apologized for that apologized for his
role in that
and of course trying to make changes
because there was a blurring of the
boundary if you like between you know
events that were happening just at the
you know the end of a working day in a
working environment a blurring of that
uh clearly to to what became in some
cases parties
you said um previously
that some of the allegations were over
the top but we're hearing from
eyewitnesses yesterday and we'll hear
more i'm sure today people of 30 or more
gathering from four o'clock they were
having wine time friday there were so
many people in the room that they
couldn't all get a seat so they had to
sit on each other's knees the child's
swing was broken there was a karaoke
machine the pm going in grabbing a glass
for himself um
do you still think it's over the top
well i never said um that those were
clearly if you've got events like that
that's not uh you know that is not
acceptable not within the rules at all
how would you describe those the well
those those are clearly wrong and that's
why the police have issued a large
number of fixed penalty notices in
respect of
some of those those events um
the point that i was making is is where
you had instances for instance at the at
the end of a
working day people in a working
environment member of staff leaving they
might have had a drink and given a toast
to that member of staff in the office
environment to leave well that's
slightly different to to something that
then turns in obviously
at the time um well yes and i think
actually if it was a uh in a working
environment and this was simply at the
end of the day to send people off it
wasn't necessarily
a breach but obviously some well some of
these events clearly work and that's why
they've issued a large number of fixed
penalty notices yeah but the events that
specifically was talking about there on
the 13th of november the police did
issue fines for people that were at that
event so it was clearly against the law
and the prime minister was there
yes and look the police have obviously
looked at this far more closely than i'm
able to they've taken witness statements
they've looked at all of the evidence
they chose to issue a fixed penalty
notice to the prime minister in respect
of one of the events the one where it
was his birthday and people brought in a
a birthday cake they've he's accepted
that he's paid that fixed penalty notice
and apologized for it the piece the
police will be closer to the detail of
this uh than than i am because i wasn't
there after all and um you know they've
chosen in this case uh not to issue a
fixed penalty notice to the prime
minister in that case and now as to why
they would have done that well they
would have based that on the evidence
that they saw
and the statements that they took at the
time
the mayor of uh london has asked
the police to explain themselves i mean
do you think he shouldn't have done that
well look i don't think we should
question the operational independence of
the police um they showed very clearly
by the fact that they issued a fixed
penalty notice to both the prime
minister and the chancellor that they
were doing their work without
fear nor favor and
they've also issued a large number of
additional fixed penalty notices in
respect of some of these other uh events
i think we should you know trust and
respect their operational independence
in these matters although you didn't
trust the independence of durham police
and and uh many of your colleagues
pushed for them to look again at what
happened with kirsten where some would
say it's one rule for one and one rule
for another
well um look it isn't there were of
course there were people that um asked
questions of the police there were
police you know the the metropolitan
police initially felt that it probably
wasn't worth going back to events that
had happened previously they were put
under pressure they decided therefore to
look at that i think people accept that
when
you're talking about um you know
politicians people in politics people in
public life uh sometimes the police will
judge that that the public interest at
test is such that they they should look
at things in a way that perhaps they
wouldn't in other circumstances and
they've done that in the case of
all of those events in downing street
very thorough examination of that and of
course durham police you know are
looking again now at that issue
surrounding kyostama but the prime
minister was presiding over a culture of
where
fines have been issued for breaking the
law when the rest of the country was in
lockdown people were sleeping at their
desks because they were so drunk they
couldn't go home the child's swing was
broken karaoke machines as i said you
know we saw the prime minister where
there were six bottles
of booze and a bottle of gin on the
table he was presiding over all of this
shouldn't he accept responsibility
well look i think he has and he's
demonstrated uh that by the statement
that he gave to parliament when sue gray
published her initial findings she
highlighted the fact that there was a
you know a culture of drinking and a
culture that enabled
the blurring of the boundary between
what was um you know an acceptable thing
at the end of a working day with people
working in an office together during
difficult times and what with them
becoming you know an event and a party
she said that they were failing she
highlighted that uh in her intern report
i suspect that a final report will build
on that and and be quite critical in
some of those
regards she said there were management
failings at many different levels and
she's already made that clear and she's
made recommendations on how
the operation at number 10 should be
changed and the prime minister's already
been clear that he will implement all of
those
some people so drunk that they had to
sleep on a sofa at dining street uh
while uh some members of the public
couldn't go to the funerals of their
loved ones
the optics of that surely the prime
minister should think
i presided over that i was responsible
for what happens in downing street
how can he possibly stay in post well
look it's not just the optics it's it's
understandable that people will feel
anger uh because there were instances
yes where people you know couldn't
attend uh funerals of close friends that
couldn't visit loved ones and of course
we absolutely recognize that the prime
minister recognizes that that's why he
has apologized for the the failings of
number 10 and for his own part in that
he's come to the dispatch box several
times in parliament you know to
apologize for that he's paid that uh
fixed penalty notice he absolutely
acknowledges just how angry people will
feel
and and completely gets that and has
apologized for that but he still will
stay in post even though he misled
parliament
well i i don't think it's right to make
uh that assertion obviously there is a
you know a standards and privileges
committee that is looking at that
particular allegation what have they
decided
ministers and politicians
are not supposed to knowingly mislead
parliament but the prime minister
himself was also given a very
clear account of his own understanding
of all of those events that he attended
that he didn't regard them as parties
and he didn't regard them as breaking
the rules he's explained that that was
his uh understanding um and and
obviously where the police have said
that there were particular failings on
his part uh in in respect for at uh the
birthday party where the the cake was
brought in uh well then you know he's
he's acknowledged that and he's paid
that fixed penalty but if the committee
finds otherwise that he did in fact
mislead parliament then he must go
surely well let's let's let the
committee do its work i don't want to
get into hypotheticals uh here um uh you
know there are lots of parliamentary
processes of this sort um he said fine
let the let the committee uh investigate
this look at it
but obviously they're going to want to
take evidence from him they're going to
want to talk to him and we should let
that process run its course and not get
ahead of ourselves
um we could talk about that um all day
but of course there was another couple
of things that i want to ask you about
not least
the rail strike rail maritime union
voting to go on a national strike um
you could i think i'm right in saying
consider legislation to ensure minimum
staffing levels in the event of a strike
that was something that was in your
manifesto is that something that you
would uh implement
well look obviously grant shaps is
working quite closely at the moment with
um you know the rail unions to try to
make sure that they don't go uh this
step um you know the truth is the pay
settlements haven't yet um you know even
been
discussed there are some important
reforms and changes that are going to
need to be made on things like ticket
offices some of which aren't really um
used anymore and um they're not it's not
viable to keep them all open there are
digital technologies that we can use to
make processes work better to help uh
passengers there are technological
things that will improve rail safety but
my question is would the government
consider changing the law to ensure
minimum staffing levels as was suggested
in your manifesto well of course we
don't rule any of these things out but
at the moment what we want to try to do
is to to work with the unions and to get
some constructive engagement here with
them um there are some real challenges
facing the railways during the pandemic
huge amounts of public subsidy had to go
to keep the rail network uh running with
passenger numbers down
passenger numbers you know remain down
and that means we are going to have to
change the way certain things work and
change certain projects
we're not ruling anything out but but
you know um what i'm trying to say okay
is in the first instance in these things
you know obviously we try to engage
constructively uh you know with the rail
unions and the workforce in each of
these cases final question before i let
you go uh ukraine last night pleading
with the royal navy
to go to odessa to try to stop that
blockade of the port we were speaking to
your colleague yesterday he said that at
grant chaps of course he said that if
that blockade continues more people are
likely to die around the world from
starvation than will die in the war in
ukraine are we looking again at the
royal navy going well look um there
aren't any plans to send the the royal
navy to the black sea however what we
what we are looking at is other uh
corridors to try to get some of those um
grain stores out of ukraine
i understand there's sort of perhaps 30
to 40 million tons of of grain there
and that's um you know a significant
proportion of the current world stocks
which is probably around 230 million
tons it's very important in these
situations when you have
this kind of uh of stress on the system
that you keep world markets open so that
you can move grain from the countries
that have it in store to those so
overland is that what you're saying uh
yes but for other yeah exactly so uh
countries that have put in place export
bans for instance that's very
you know damaging to confidence around
the world luckily uh all of the big
producer nations recognize this and
they're all keeping their markets open
so ourselves the european union the
united states we're keeping markets open
so that grain can flow around the world
but i know that there is some thought
being given by the g7 as to how we can
potentially get safe corridors to be
able to move
some of those uh some of those grain
stores out by land okay for now thanks
very much indeed minister much
appreciated thank you